est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
aller dans une boîte échangiste tous les
samedis soirs
avec une campagne pour les
soutiens-gorge vanderbra
c'est une jolie fille qui disait
regardez-moi dans les yeux j'ai dit les
yeux et bien Frédéric cados ce soir elle
est là
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une première fois en 1994
et vous m'avez dit à cette époque là
j'étais absolument désolé aucun homme ne
m'a jamais dit tu sais Eva tu as de
beaux seins
est-ce que depuis on vous l'a dit
parce que je crois que les gens ils sont
beaucoup plus intéressés par à quoi je
suis à l'intérieur et pas quoi
[Rires]
donc vous avez un destin extraordinaire
vous connaissez le destin des valeurs
sigova on a que des destins
formidable ce soir
vous êtes pas loin
alors ce soir on a vraiment des dessins
extraordinaires le Laurent Baffie qui
finira dans la peau de Sacha Guitry il
faut bien le dire
et va aussi
les années 50 et qui est devenu la
baronne
je suis sûr qu'entre vous il y a un truc
moi aussi
vous avez une tendresse pour lui quoi
vous plaisiez beaucoup à mener à youb
aussi
a donné quoi
ça veut travailler sur le service public
ça s'est même pas le début du mot la fin
du mot petit indice
la Tchéquie
alors dans un petit village au nord de
la Tchéquie ils s'en fout de ce pays
voilà et heureusement de pays si tu veux
on va voir comment les nichons
alors votre père était électricien dans
une compagnie minière votre mère était
secrétaire et à l'époque avant la
Révolution de Velours avant bracel
lavabel justement vous viviez dans un
pays difficile enfin à l'époque on
rendiez pas compte évidemment c'est
comme quand Nadine de Rothschild
habitait à Puteaux sous la chape de
plomb du communisme donc vous ne saviez
rien de ce qui se passait à l'ouest à
l'époque et votre grand-mère vous
faisait des confidences en secret elle
vous disait quoi votre grand-mère quand
je vais vous parler vous étiez petit
vous parlait de l'époque d'avant le
communisme
ma grand-mère en fait qu'elle a eu
qu'elle était moins 104 ans elle était
très ouverte elle chantait la vieille la
vieille hymne
elle m'a raconté les histoires il m'a
raconté comment s'est passé dans les
dans les comptes
donc elle était très belle elle m'a
toujours dit il faut jamais raconter à
personne parce que c'est comme ça qu'on
était allé en prison
le totalitaire et pourtant vous dites
qu'à l'époque du communisme les gens
étaient plus solidaires et
qu'aujourd'hui ils sont plus jaloux plus
en vieux
un peu
plus jaloux parce que avant il y avait
avec pas la différence tout on avait la
même chose il y avait pas le choix et
maintenant il y a les gens qui sont plus
riches il y a des gens qui sont plus
talentueux qu'ils ont envie de
travailler le plus et bien sûr c'est là
qui reste encore avec leur
penser dans le vieil assistant ils sont
jaloux parce qu'ils sont ils sont
feignants ils sont alors à l'époque
quand vous étiez petit disons ils
étaient pas un fantasme comme vous dites
vous-même d'ailleurs vous étiez plutôt
plate non comme fille
très mince et je me suis développée
j'étais assez
retardée pour cette partie maintenant
jalouse un peu de votre sœur qui avait 3
ans de plus que vous
que c'est avec les hommes c'est elle qui
était pulpeuse telle qui avait les
dessins
[Musique]
et c'est toi qui ramasse tout
ma soeur maintenant elle est elle est
toujours très belle et je trouve qu'elle
est elle a des enfants elle a eu un
élevage de canon comme ça
c'est des belles filles
bien et alors un jour voilà où c'est
extraordinaire son histoire ils habitent
donc à ludvinaf près de la frontière
allemande comme je l'ai dit et un jour
ils vont à Prague avec vos parents vous
partez après pour visiter des musées et
vous rencontrez une amie Prague qui vous
dit Éva il y a une agence française qui
fait un casting qui organise un concours
il y avait 400 filles et c'est vous qui
gagnez
je voulais pas aller
c'était dans un hôtel un hôtel
Intercontinental c'est un neuvième étage
je me rappelle très bien je suis arrivée
il y avait toutes les filles qui se
ressemblaient à ma sœur donc je me suis
pas trouvé belle je me suis dit mais
qu'est-ce que je fais ici j'étais je
partais tout de suite je partais mais la
femme de Paris qui est venu de organiser
cette concours il m'a remarqué et elle a
couru après moi j'étais en attente dans
l'ascenseur elle m'avait dit tu veux
venir à Paris
avec vous c'est-à-dire que jusqu'à l'âge
de 16 ans quand vous alliez au cinéma
l'après-midi que le film se termine à 8h
il fait très la maison à 8h05 donc c'est
vrai et raconter l'histoire si tu veux
et là donc vous débarquez à Paris et ce
qui vous a le plus fasciné c'est les
étages de fruits et légumes
c'était pas vraiment c'était bien sûr le
choix parce que on avait pas mais je
trouve je crois que c'était la
possibilité là que c'était ouvert qui
n'ont pas eu peur qu'il y a quelqu'un
qui va aller voler les trucs comme ça
surtout des pommes de terre non c'est
très ouais c'est une tradition on est on
mange beaucoup de la viande et la pomme
de terre je reste fascinée par les
gadgets ou pas
à la tentative
il se dit les filles de l'Est c'est un
peu encore les trucs alors vous avez du
mal à vous adapter non pas à Paris mais
aux Parisiens ouais je pense ça que vous
parlez de cette histoire où je suis
allée acheter une baguette à la place de
dire une j'ai dit un et
ils m'ont dit en disant que qu'est-ce
que je veux qu'il comprenne pas la
baguette c'est la baguette si j'avais
dit une un il voulait pas me comprendre
[Rires]
je suis fasciné mais c'est vrai quand
vous avez dit braguette bon je vais le
regard de Nadine plein de compassion
pour vous mais c'est incroyable est en
train progressivement de tomber un petit
peu amoureux
de faire fortune alors vous avez été
très surprise par les prix en arrivant à
Paris et quand vos parents sont venus
vous visitez à Paris vous rendre visite
vous les avez logé à l'hôtel cost et
vous cachez les prix parce que vous
aviez un peu honte du prix que ça
coûtait non parce que ma maman elle
pensait à tout ce qui est elle pouvait
avoir en Tchécoslovaquie parce que les
prix entre ici et là-bas
alors question cinéma vous avez eu moins
la main heureuse vous allez jouer dans
les Anges Gardiens avec Depardieu et
clavier
et puis alors un film s'appelle l'amico
Delore de Vincenzo Salem qu'on a pas
trop vu et là just for the time being
par Jil Brandon qui est un ex de Santa
Barbara mais surtout là où je veux en
venir c'est que vous avez refusé de
jouer dans le Kubrick ce film qui est
notre fine culte Frédéric j'adore
film sur le couple qui a été fait
c'était très difficile à dessiner parce
qu'il faudrait qu'il fait un film toutes
les 20 ans et il est mort quel dommage
mais la rôle qui m'a été proposée je
voulais je même aujourd'hui je n'aurais
pas accepté parce que le rôle c'était
c'était pas
c'était pas c'était présenté pour moi
comme un corps comme une beauté
moi je suis je suis dans la partout dans
le château c'est dans la soirée dans le
château
dans un métier je veux pas faire la même
chose des annonces
[Musique]
pour la même rôle oui
parce qu'en 94 vous m'aviez dit je n'ai
pas encore rencontré l'homme de ma vie
j'ai compris en vous posant la question
que ce serait pas moi depuis on vous a
vu beaucoup avec vous j'ai même été
marié avec Tico Torres le batteur de Bon
Jovi mariage qui a duré 2 ans et alors
un jour il y a une histoire je voudrais
savoir où ça en est parce que l'histoire
est formidable vous êtes un matin sur le
port de New York dans un hangar en train
de faire des photos pour Calvin Klein
avec Jean-Baptiste mondinot avec un
mannequin qui s'appelle Kelly ripi
faites des photos avec lui et alors à un
moment mon Dino Jean-Baptiste mignon le
photographe appelle la directrice de la
communication de Calvin Klein il dit
j'ai même plus besoin de les diriger ils
sont vraiment tombés amoureux c'est à
dire que pendant la photo vous êtes
tombé amoureuse de ce Kelly ripi donc je
suis extrêmement jaloux bien entendu et
alors est-ce que ça dure toujours c'est
une vieille histoire
on lance un appel
un moment positif dans cette émission
très positive
j'ai fait une connerie d'en parler
tu fais du mal
ça fait toujours du mal parce que je
crois
que chaque fois on s'y met ensemble avec
quelqu'un on pense que c'est pour pour
la fille pour tout le temps et en fait
on cherche on cherche on cherche et
aujourd'hui vous voulez lancer un appel
à la télévision je crois pas que ça va
être si public mais pas besoin je crois
ça a marché
on a plus envie depuis
embarqué parce qu'on a plus jamais revu
bien ben écoutez on va voir justement ce
que vous seriez prête à faire ou pas par
amour parce que c'est important que les
Français soient au courant ça s'appelle
l'interview par amour et vous savez que
[Musique]
on ne bouge pas pendant le jingle
il y a deux connards de rebelles ce soir
heureusement que le cadreur est baffiste
et qui bouge la caméra parce que donc
par amour est-ce que vous seriez prête à
sacrifier vos ambitions professionnelles
le vrai amour oui vous y croyez toujours
vrai amour
heureusement
c'est pas ton question
[Rires]
ok est-ce que par amour vous seriez
prête à refuser un film avec Steven
Spielberg
pour l'amour pour tout pour avoir
ce que tu tournes avec
exactement la théorie de madame la
baronne qui dit quand on aime quelqu'un
le laisse vivre
j'espère que les autres en prendront de
la grève intelligent c'est tout vous
avez raison
est-ce que par amour vous retourneriez
vivre en République tchèque
en renonçant à toute la technologie
[Applaudissements]
et nous ramène en groupe du monde
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
vous faire refaire les seins
[Musique]
un vrai amour est-ce que par amour vous
seriez prête à ne pas faire d'enfant
ça c'est difficile
un mec qui vous dit je t'aime on se
marie mais moi je déteste les enfants
j'en veux pas
c'est les fruits de l'amour donc c'est
automatique c'est naturel que ça vient
est-ce que par amour vous êtes de Riez
votre votre homme a caché le corps de
quelqu'un qui vient de tuer
un livre là-dessus
l'avantage et la littérature
c'est que tout semble avoir un sens
subitement alors ça c'est une question
importante c'est la question Clotilde
Courau Clotilde de Kourou qui est une
jeune actrice très talentueuse
d'ailleurs nous a dit que par amour
quand elle était plus jeune elle
embrassait 100 fois de suite les
chaussettes sales de son fiancé
vous le feriez vous
aussi à vous non non
vous avez jamais vécu avec le batteur de
Bon Jovi en même temps
il devait avoir 20-25 ans et j'en avais
que par amour vous excepteriez que votre
fiancé et une maîtresse
j'aurais très mal
mais si vous voulez mais vraiment vous
voulez qu'il soit heureux
c'est compliqué
à trois
on était en pleine mégot Nadine elle a
pas besoin d'être assisté à son âge
pas possible bon oui mais un peu comme
ça quand même
[Musique]
dit c'est pas non est-ce que par amour
vous seriez prête à aller dans une boîte
échangiste tous les samedis soirs
oui
[Applaudissements]
on y va ce soir c'est pas non c'est
non
un samedi sur de Eva un samedi sur deux
tous les 15 jours parce que je pense à
l'amour et si je l'aime vraiment
qu'est-ce qui ça rapporte le mec en fait
ce qu'il veut c'est la grippe il sait
pas vraiment mais c'est en fait ces
enfants de fantasmes c'est que la une
partie de
cet homme je sais pas c'est mais non ça
me plairait pas c'est important
est-ce que par amour vous seriez prête à
devenir son esclave sexuel
et là la France entière fontaine moi le
premier d'ailleurs
Frédéric
cet homme qui réalise son qui arrive à
imposer à la France entière des trucs de
malade
est-ce que
par amour vous seriez prête à grossir de
10 kilos
si le type aime bien les Rubens les
formes vous êtes d'accord
[Applaudissements]
votre invité ce soir
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu